[Música]
qué harían si les dijera que dentro de
esta aula dentro de este auditorio puede
haber un satélite y que este satélite
tiene la capacidad de operar a 400
kilómetros de altura además puede dar
una vuelta a la tierra cada 90 minutos
de qué tamaño se lo imaginan
me creerían que esta clase de tecnología
cabe en la palma de mi mano
la verdad es que hace algunos años yo ni
siquiera me lo hubiera imaginado lo
único que conocía de temas espaciales
era lo que veía en las noticias incluso
en la televisión y las películas
cuántos de ustedes no hemos visto
películas como el apolo 11 gravity el
reciente estreno de up astra y muchas
otras más que nos han hecho creer que
trabajar en esta clase de proyectos es
demasiado complejo
y saben algo la verdad es que pues sí lo
es por eso yo nunca pensé trabajar para
una misión espacial
me llamo erika sevilla y hoy estoy para
compartirles que soy parte de un equipo
que desarrolló un satélite que irá al
espacio y que dará diez seis vueltas a
la tierra en tan solo un día
permite mostrarles cómo luce este
satélite del cual les estoy hablando
les da una réplica a tamaño real así
como lo ven idéntico de aste exacto
1 primer nanosatélite mexicano diseñado
y construido por un equipo
multidisciplinario de 60 personas
integrado profesores y estudiantes y
saben que es lo mejor somos mexicanos
gracias
y trabajamos en una universidad en
puebla
trabajamos en un país y gracias al apoyo
de la nasa y de la agencia espacial
mexicana será lanzado al espacio el 4 de
diciembre de 2019 este año
así como lo ven este pequeño satélite
tan solo mide 10 centímetros por cada
lado y tiene un peso aproximado de un
kilogramo para ser más exacta este
satélite pesa tan solo 920 gramos debido
a estas características que tiene del
tamaño la forma y el peso esta clase de
satélites es conocido como clase club
sad
estos satélites así de pequeños como lo
ven resuelven diferentes tipos de
misiones algunas misiones son de
observación a la tierra todos en algún
momento hemos visto una foto tomada a
nuestro planeta desde el espacio están
de acuerdo otro tipo de misiones que
resuelven estos satélites son de
telecomunicaciones y algunos otros son
de demostraciones de ciencia y
tecnología ese es el caso de as text a
duno para ponernos un poquito en
contexto de que hará esta pequeña cajita
en el espacio les voy a decir que un
club' sap pasa por una estación terrena
alrededor de dos veces al día
en esas dos veces al día tan solo tiene
entre cuatro y cinco minutos para bajar
la mayor cantidad de datos posibles de
su misión
nuestra misión llamada misión águila lo
que nos permitirá es maximizar la
cantidad de datos y la frecuencia que
tenemos para bajar los datos de misiones
de clase club sat
aceptado uno será lanzado desde cabo
cañaveral en florida en un cohete falcon
9 de una misión de spacex si la empresa
del destino la estación espacial
internacional
una vez que el satélite llega a la
estación espacial internacional en el
primer cuatrimestre del 2020 desplegarán
desde la estación el satélite para que
pueda comenzar a estar en órbita y
comience con su misión la cual consiste
en demostrar que un satélite de clase
club sab puede comunicarse y establecer
relación con con satélites de clase
comercial de una constelación de
satélites llamada global está de esa
manera el satélite de esa constelación
que cache l2 de nuestro satélite podrá
ponerlo en diferentes estaciones
terrenas para que a su vez esa
información la depositen en un
repositorio en internet y tengamos
acceso a los datos
en paralelo en la estación de arena que
se ha instalado en la universidad
estaremos monitoreando el paso de
nuestro satélite en esas dos ocasiones
al día que les acabo de comentar a
manera de que también recibamos los
datos de nuestra misión
de eso haremos una comparación de los
datos para revisar la calidad obtenida
pero y como hemos hecho esto nos hemos
basado en la metodología de la nasa en
el ciclo de vida de un proyecto como lo
hacen ellos nos organizamos en once
equipos de trabajo diferente cada uno
con una función específica y fundamental
para el éxito de este proyecto con un
equipo que no pudiera entregar lo que
tenía que entregar no estaríamos
hablando de que este satélite estará en
el espacio
así mismo
hemos trabajado con mentores como andrés
martínez y josé hernández andrés
martínez ejecutivo de programas
espaciales de la nasa y josé hernández
nuestros astronauta mexicano quien ellos
nos han dado un coach es bastante bueno
en cómo trabajar en una misión espacial
y sobre todo cómo trabajar en equipo
en cómo hacemos para que podamos
coordinarnos once equipos de trabajo
diferente y 60 personas
pues para eso yo soy la project manager
mi función es coordinar y articular los
esfuerzos de todos los equipos y de
todos los integrantes del equipo ayudó a
que podamos tener una planeación de las
tareas que tenemos que entregar así
también las dependencias que hay entre
un equipo y otro y también de esta
manera planteamos los posibles riesgos a
los que nos podríamos enfrentar les
estoy hablando de once equipos
diferentes
tuvimos equipos de electrónica tuvimos
equipos de programación de mecánica de
una instalación de estación de arena
tenemos un equipo que también va a
operar esta misión una vez que esté en
el espacio
y sabían ustedes que para poder lanzar
algo al espacio necesitamos cumplir con
muchos reglamentos permisos y obtener
licencias con tan solo uno de ellos que
no hubiéramos cumplido no estaría
platicando les aquí que estamos a punto
de lanzar un satélite no nos subirían al
cohete pero gracias a que también
tuvimos un equipo dedicado a la parte de
gestión y obtención de licencias y
permisos hoy puedo estar aquí platicando
les de esto para lograrlo
se trabajó en conjunto con el instituto
federal de telecomunicaciones y con la
secretaría de comunicaciones y
trasportes para crear procesos que
ayuden a futuras misiones de clase club
sap a tener reglamentaciones de
lanzamiento de estos proyectos esto es
un gran paso para gméxico en proyectos
espaciales
ahora bien saben qué es lo más curioso
de eso project manager de este equipo
que cuando yo era estudiante igual que
como muchos de ustedes aquí en el
auditorio
no me gustaba para nada los trabajos en
equipo cuántos de ustedes no les ha
pasado que les dicen armen equipos de
cuatro y cinco personas y la verdad es
que la primera pregunta que yo hacía es
tiene que ser en equipo prefería hacerlo
sola con tal de no estar detrás de los
demás a cuántos de ustedes no les ha
pasado eso vueltas que da la vida porque
hoy pues soy parte de un equipo que no
coordinó a tres o cuatro coordino a 60
personas ahora bien hasta exacto uno no
sólo es un satélite de verdad que nos ha
dejado muchísimo aprendizaje tanto a los
profesores como a los estudiantes ya
enriquecido bastante la colaboración que
hay entre nosotros dentro y fuera del
aula
es increíble ver el crecimiento que los
estudiantes han tenido para mí es un
orgullo estar aquí y ser la portavoz de
todos ellos porque de verdad muchos
entraron en primer semestre muchos
entraron con conocimientos básicos de
temas espaciales igual que algunos de
nosotros y hoy es increíble ver cómo se
presentan ante un panel de revisión de
la nasa y pueden estar en laboratorios
especializados
hemos pasado dos largos años de este
trabajo así también hemos pasado por
seis evaluaciones diferentes y el
laboratorio y el satélite fue sometido a
diferentes pruebas en laboratorios
especializados de la nasa todo esto para
que hoy pueda decirles que hemos logrado
el primer éxito de nuestra misión el
cual consiste en entregar un satélite
certificado y listo para vuelo a la
nación y que este próximo 30 de
septiembre estará siendo empacado dentro
del desplegado que irá en el cohete
para que el próximo 4 de octubre lo
estemos entregando al programa de la
estación espacial internacional
este proyecto no ha sido el esfuerzo de
solo una persona este proyecto es la
suma del esfuerzo de todos y gracias a
eso como project manager y ha aprendido
tres cosas fundamentales número uno
identifica el talento de las personas
que están a tu alrededor
esta manera te podrá ayudar a colocarlos
en el equipo correcto y que ellos se
sientan contentos con lo que hacen
número 2 y muy importante valora a tu
equipo de trabajo y número 3 motiva a
este equipo de trabajo créanme que con
esto con un equipo unido podremos lograr
el éxito de cualquier misión espacial y
de lo que sea eso ha sido una clave para
el éxito de nosotros hasta tú no tal vez
vaya a ser un pequeño satélite para el
espacio pero para nosotros es un gran
paso para la ingeniería espacial
mexicana y les aseguro que es el primer
proyecto de muchos otros más que están
por venir por eso en este escenario y
con todos ustedes presentes quiero
decirles muy emocionada bienvenidos a la
nueva era espacial mexicana
muchas gracias